hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are playing WWE 2k 17 for the
PlayStation and we're going to do this
in a very different way we are not just
going to do a typical let's play where
we'll find funny moments from the game
instead or let's look what's happening
now stock it we have started a new
career or a foot spin for that kick a
new career with a new wrestler you've
probably already seen in the thumbnail
but let's just see what happens anywhere
so here's the man's who is finn balor
here we go this is a painful move must
be it one two three
the champion will celebrate so finn
balor is the champion we're going to
create a wrestler we're going to take
that title and we're going to make our
way through NXT look what is secret is
that she guessed already we've we've
made Jeff Hardy we are gonna take him
all the way from NXT but the performance
sentence all the way up through a raw
through Smackdown to Wrestlemania itself
will probably face Brock Lesnar so over
the next few weeks we're going to try
and get through this and get get from
the bottom to the top so first thing we
need to do is sign up for our next tier
and hopefully impress people let's see
was in charge it's Prince Albert do you
remember him Jeff remember him beat him
a few times this is my ring this is my
home
hello a ribbon let's do this
whoa did you see around my guy what you
saw last night it's not talent it's hard
work
guys like Finn Kevin and Sammy they ran
the same ropes you're running they did
the same training that you are all about
to do there are no advantages like
talent and luck the only thing that will
separate you from the pack is how hard
you're willing to work for it you do
that and one day you might find yourself
with that same title you saw Finn hold
it I will outlet I will
okay now pair up I want to see what you
got you want to see what Jeff Hardy's
got who's my first victim the guy in
bright blue you going down pal oh oh the
reversal system yep similar to last year
I'll look at that trophies already
trophies galore let's see if we can
Irish wit well let's not press that Oh
what breaker yes so Jeff let's even go
to the toy he can't got the top rope he
has top rope phobia so you must have to
unlock it which means we're going to
have to win a few matches before we can
get to the top rope what I'm gonna be an
illness one of those superstars that
just doesn't move over and over again
and again and again and again
let's do somewhat differently I like
that I wonder what signature move is not
chancing is going to work there's no
show I wonder what these right finishing
move time let's see what we've got
it looks some sort of fun bundle slam
what the heck was that
right we'll give it a name that's called
the spinning looks at grappler from now
on yeah Performance Centre Simon your
pal Bert
I think we did all right there but from
the Honorable trainers I think Albert's
gonna say we're the best thing he's ever
seen since sliced bread
pretty good for a rookie you're rustling
is solid but not exciting and definitely
not on the level of a diadem a superstar
over the next few weeks we'll be working
on solidifying your rustling style if
you nail that down we'll talk about the
next steps now go take a break
Alba is telling Jeff Hardy how to
wrestle there's issues there's issues
right so next day let's see what we have
to do today we will impress Albert
hopefully I'll get into the ring
oh he's brought his cronies with him
okay this is it we want to see how you
fare against a real superstar show us
what you can do against Samoa Joe this
is your first real test you know what
tell us where you stand
come on in Samoa Joe seriously it's
gonna be fine Albert you've got nothing
to worry about
in fact Jeff and Samoa Joe wrestled many
times at TNA let's see if we can
recreate some of that magic now I've one
of those quit Finn come on this is it
one two three yeah what to try right
though to be serious even though oh that
look painful we want to lose this match
you missed think that's silly but if we
beat some audio we skip NXT and part of
our journey is to get the NXT title II
thought it was gonna deal one of those
surfboards then remember those
now it can't be done can be done right
second rope one one move warrior oh I
quite like the big the grapple
techniques in this and the striking
looks pretty good and the soundtrack is
phenomenal
really enjoying the soundtrack
Oh two men have an acquittal that's my
favorite movie so far so we want to
loose or in fact I'm trying not to lose
but we're going to lose anyway
yeah yeah okay remember we wanted that
we want to lose we want to go to NXT sup
my brother okay pretty good still room
for improvement but a decent performance
nonetheless keep doing what you're doing
kid and you'll be a WWE Superstar and no
time right go ahead and take a break
you've earned it we are going to NXT so
we need to change what we're wearing
because this does not suit Jeff Hardy so
next task impress everyone NXT attire
change
yes crazy Jeff hurry it didn't have
Hardy so I work for Harry instead I
think it sounds pretty good got the
gloves on now with a face pinned up
against the guy's name what's the call
again Zachary to win any Zachary Ryder
pursue to set us drug you into the
middle at Koresh showboating now um will
snap your neck he's dead a message to
the entire WWE locker room here oh
that's nice if you get more than one
mode from the second row I wonder if he
could recover from this guy's oh I miss
Jeff Hardy so much oh there it is the
spinning tops at grappler chief it
changes every game spinning looks like
Dracula now that is just dangerous just
doing snow angels this must be it here
we go
he's going for the pen oh no see oh nice
the singles matches come to a head as
the debut for NXT well done Jeffrey spit
anoxic grappler backstage whose round
who nice work out there tonight thank
you keep that up you have a bright
future here I will keep though and I'll
beat you for the Intercontinental title
do you remember that one triple huh oh
the guy line is a bit off there so we're
on main event as well
we'll check in is it Baron Corbin down
doesn't seem to be getting milk haven't
won by count-out yeah this is so
dangerous so if I put him down now these
two busy
for the side effect he's done
this baby tomatoes will get back in he's
not going to get back up to taunt in
fact try and coincide this for the end
just winner and now that is a winning
pause well done Jeff the purple suits in
much better don't you think
roach neat is sort the top of his head
out if you are stuck like I am and
there's a line across the head you can
use a letter and just resize it and
change the color but it's in white and I
can change that to skin color now and
look there you go
no more frown on his forehead well this
did a few more wrinkles there but looks
a little bit better start this man this
guy will not leave me alone
so shoot me - ah deserve that he
deserved that
so Tyson Kidd won't leave me alone in
fact he gives more attention to me than
he does his own wife looks like we're in
for some fireworks - oh that did not go
well
right there we go Tyson get used to
eating Matt I don't mean my brother get
up and I've one of them spinning nobody
gets up from glasses you can't recover
from this and by now you would have
expected one of these galleries snow
angels this must be the end really has
it happened yet Ty's here we go
yeah the match is over by the way I'm
using Lisa's theme tune this is the
confrontation nice and good waiting door
jumping me stop interrupting me
referee I'm very sorry right here nice
and get up I've got to drop the bat then
tell them together should I display
that's a shame
get up Tyson
but that extent here
Oh doing the Ric Flair let's see if the
rest of the Ric Flair going on lacking
any job yeah the Ric Flair but it well
so Jeff is in his first saw tirade
against Tyson Kidd
this is aftermath I'm sorry after the
match I'm the shooter the end of it
there now so this one's almost over the
crowd loved it coming up the only one
who felt that in rhyme in the tag team
with Tyson well they finally decided
who's gonna start this ad
you can't tag yourself in fella I have
to make contact with it as you know what
crap it I'm just gonna make sure I put
you off for the entire match I love it
Oh
thunderous authority cage on there Sasso
not too uptight continues you know what
Tyson Tyson Tyson up big oh I'm going
I'm going for the tagging his partner
just I don't want none of you Tyson like
in a fun getting about it oh we got a
handicap badge the nine count just get
any wind just get in your wind inside
what the hell
Tyson Kidd deliberately go himself
counted out what a guy we have one of
the best talents of blacks back again
I've been in four times so far I forget
I love this intro' oh the bearded man is
going to run into me in the shin if you
want have a fight without on your rules
just give me a moment sir I do love that
split screen it's brilliant we have the
sledgehammer triple h style mists dragon
yeah don't run it on my container to
deteriorate kill learn from my ex I
don't think he'll try that again
right Sami Zayn I want that belt from
around your waist and now I know I can
run in on matches I will try it now
when's the best time when is sauce guard
Anson
I wonder belt I wonder belt should I
give him a running bulldog what would
you recommend I will just sort of kick
Oh Oh that went wrong this is the belt
that I want I'm here for this
Sammy have a closer
so to get to some easier I need to beat
this guy up a little bit more there we
go our Twisted Fate that's the better
finisher
I've got rid of this spinning looks like
grappler the crowd loved it but we need
to get back to Sammy's in right Sammy
this is a table for a you sir ha ha come
and see it coming to close up come over
here on know that better not are you
joking
that is the worst ending to a match ever
got to keep going for some easier we're
just gonna keep this going until he
gives us a title shot sure what type of
competitor is favorite when you step out
some brilliant sting some it I want to
be used in the ring destructive person
so let's get you in the ring coming I'm
sorry let's get you in the ring Sammy
the best really sorry fell it wasn't
intended it
I can't get him in the ring right you
know what inside the ring they're gonna
get counted out instead sorry summit
I'll take your title next time money
that title I think we have is next much
by the way have you seen how he
celebrates what's really serious buzzing
you remember each crazy Jeff Perry yeah
yeah what a guy in a crowd here tonight
joy to the top high risk this must be
the one this Baron guy keeps repeatedly
attacking us Marty so I can't actually
get a rivalry going with Sammy's in for
the title it comes this guy repeatedly
Oh booty repeatedly keeps getting
through matches eventually going back
and attacking
so I'm bringing in three or four five
six times in a row now I just can't get
rivalry Sami Zayn going by I love fun
bond take a look at that again oh so
good he's too busy ruining the Battle of
this batcher then he goes okay it always
kicks out shake my booty back to Sami
Zayn again we're gonna try one more time
to get this belt off him in this first
episode what I don't think it's gonna be
possible
I really don't want on what the tension
rose I miss you Jeff so much let's pick
up the win
there we go still not against them I
can't figure out how to get a title much
should be right I get a title fight so
I'm just going to be mocked if he keeps
up this pace this my guard is repeatedly
let's give him a jab I'm not arming of
the it's a drop and I hope we could get
a duck as a precaution we all knew this
situation I think we're coming to the
end of this first episode now so Jeff
Hardy set off he's in the NXT he is
doing really well he's in the top two or
three but I can't get a title fight
so next episode I guarantee shouldn't
lose here but I guarantee we will win
the NXT title and we will progress up to
a Smackdown or raw I would have said
rise the better one but these days it
seems to be smack down line so it's
going to be a difficult time but we're
going to get there with Jeff so keep
watching hopefully of like this and if
you did I will make more episodes so
hopefully we'll pick it up from that
pay-per-view I will be able to win the
match straight away and then progress on
and take over the WWE
I've been Adam from Playstation grenade
I'll see you next time